preparing you could go live hmm okay I
can see it's a go life it says go live
good okay I'm gonna give you co-host
permission and then I'm gonna do a
little introduction to you I'm gonna
make you co-host then you can share your
screen hello out there if anybody's
watching we are now alive we should be
now alive online and it's a great
pleasure to welcome all my guests to the
into the impossible arthur c clarke a
center for human imaginations into the
impossible podcast series this is a
subset a playlist that we have called
brilliant minds and that were that we're
conducting with with all sorts of
brilliant guests and i was saying it's
not only a pleasure to welcome great
scientists of all kinds but especially
when it's a friend and especially when
that friend is also a colleague and
especially when that friend is such a
amazing human being such as Chi Chuan me
who I'm glad to call a colleague at UCSD
how are you doing hi Sean great I'm
doing great and it has been busy in the
past several months and it's especially
this week oh yeah I think we should she
had a news with the outside community
yeah it's amazing yeah congratulations
on these results and they've generated
not a small amount of interest and
controversy even some hoping that people
will enjoy this discussion I thought I'd
start off with a quick highlight of who
you are and what you are so I'm gonna
share my screen let's do it like this
and we welcome people out there we're
just getting started about ten thirty
six and the west coast of the United
States and California and I I reached
out the Chi Chuan earlier this week to
to have a little discussion about these
fantastic results which came out on the
17th which seems like like a month ago
but was really only two days ago as you
pointed out on Wednesday was released a
paper
observation of excess electronic recoil
events in Zenon 1-ton you might not
think that this would set the world on
fire but it's some of the interesting
details that are just being cut off at
the bottom there about relationship to
other exotic things called axioms and so
forth I hope we'll get into all that
good stuff I just want to highlight this
slide that I saw that I really enjoy
always seeing all my friends on Zenon
one town including professor Alena prio
who was our Margaret burbage visiting
scholar this year at UCSD and Chi Chuan
helped to bring her to our fine
University UC San Diego a rich tradition
not only people there are very brilliant
minds but in particular people made
massive contributions to our
understanding of a dark matter and other
exotic phenomena including Margaret
Burbage and that's of course the
namesake for the professorship that
Elaine up real the PI of xenon Anton
experiment leads and she had that
position so it's a great thrill but of
course it's a great thrill to see guys
one up there is he did you find that
Amina I do I see her she's staring right
at me actually nothing else up in the
apartment in Brooklyn yeah yeah she's
gotten a lot of attention lately and
she's handling it was such such
graciousness etc and you know she enjoys
the spotlight but I think she she also
does such a phenomenal job as an
ambassador of science and a mentor to
people like you and even like me the
brief amount of time have come to know
her I've just been really honored and
blessed to have this great great
wonderful you know relationship with her
so thank you for bringing her here I
wouldn't have met her otherwise so I
refer people if you're interested we did
an event with Chi Chuan Alina and some
other folks in the occasion of the
chasing Einstein movie release that we
did at UCSD a day before UCSD was
effectively locked down so for a corona
virus so Chi Chuan was part of that and
Elena and I did a an episode of into the
impossible also back in March
during her same visit that was actually
I think a day before her birthday when
she turned 29 no I don't know I don't
know how old she is but she's she's
phenomenal she also has a chunk of did
you know this she has a piece of dark
matter named after her D are you aware
of this matter it's an asteroid oh yeah
I know that yeah okay good so kai-shan
there he is in the upper left box I
tried to put a little frame around him
just to highlight me and when we brought
him to UCSD I was a huge champion of
trying to get him here what I also like
about the slide it shows all the paths
this is a technical meeting this isn't
like the press release right and it
isn't about me getting you know one
month ago you know we're basically
preparing for the next stage called a Z
no Anton yeah I want to learn more about
that hopefully we can chat more about
that but what I love about this video
this screen captures you know you see
all the normal you know kinds of faces
and different different zoom backgrounds
but then you see people with like
windmill in the background and then you
see some little kids in the background
and ya know to campus so I just think
it's lovely to see that you know science
is done by human beings and and we have
lives and families and it's a wonderful
humanization so I like that you let off
are your team let off their discussion
with that here's I think iPhones
homepage at UCSD it's called an e group
at UC San Diego and subtitle is your
mission your mission in your and your
group that you've developed your brand
is to explore the nature of dark matter
and neutrinos and I hope we'll talk
about all those and maybe I think you
need to revise the web page you know the
mission statement needs to add accion's
you know although matter maybe it's not
but well I want to get into that there's
also links to find out more about his
group because as we know professors are
just me or figure heads and they you
know kind of rainmakers four of these
experiments and all the work is really
done by our postdocs graduate students
and undergraduates and cry chuan has the
second best at all of set UC San Diego
now I'm just kidding you you guys are
phenomenal I love I love the fact that
you're here in San Diego doing this hard
core research including which I hope
you'll loose cry
these really massive detectors it's
impossible that from the Silla cartoon
that I stole from your Dropbox slides to
really get a handle on this I will put
some resources and links to ways that
people can learn more and connect to you
after this is done recording we're going
to talk about this hopefully you'll walk
us through of a version I'm sure of this
type of slide near in your presentation
and it's just really cool will nerd out
a little bit but will also explain what
the meaning is and perhaps maybe I like
to get philosophical I like to think
about what are the implications for the
grandest questions of the universe the
nature of matter the origin of matter
and and perhaps exotic matter such as
possibly the result of your Wednesday's
detection our announcement so that's the
end of my slides I'm now gonna turn it
over to the driver's seat to Chi Chuan
and I'm gonna go back to the meeting
here I'm gonna stop sharing okay - are
you able to share your slide sir okay I
will share my slides and I hope I don't
need to go through all my slides which
was presented by our fantastic graduate
student on Wednesday but I will
illustrate some of the results and
people I interested let me share my
screen all right can you see it I was
just yeah watch that so Xena one-ton is
really our current experiment and it's
started from almost 19 years ago when I
was a graduate student at a time we
started with Zeno 10 which is as a 10
kilogram of experiment and as my fun
graduate thesis project and it turns out
that the technology we use with the
two-faced Dino in producing chamber
really is fantastic for dogma detection
and it missing so we have B with is
larger in a large detector encoding Xena
100 which is a hundred kilogram detector
and then starting 2012 we started
prepared as ton scale this is the first
town scale experiment using the cuisine
on time purchasing chamber for document
search there are other experiment in the
world and also ongoing our next stage
would be Xena ain't on which is being
assembled this year and we expect to
start running soon so that would use a
total are more than a ton of the cuisine
are inside so that's the kind of our
research compiling plan and the results
in in these two years in in the last few
years they're really coming from there's
you know one time because this Louis the
background detector dogmatic tech ever
viewed and not only low background but
also a massive target with total to Tom
in a sense of target and we usually use
the one time about one ton in the
innermost that clean is a part for
document rich and I'm not going to talk
about Dark Matter search today are
because the result is really actually
not about dark matter but related but
Xena wanta has set the most constraint
limit on wimp dark matter for any dark
matter above three G V which is the
three times the mass of protons xenon
one tongue has the most constraint limit
up to a few TV or even higher so we were
a little bit kind of sad you know we
didn't see any signature of dark matter
after almost 20 years of looking and a
lot of people's effort not only
including our collaboration but also
including people from all around the
world in the US and Europe in Asia in
China Japan and it really took a lot of
effort
but but I mean for experiments like such
a big skill although we we didn't see
any signature of dark matter there's
some surprise that from time to time
especially this time and let me just
bring to the is the picture of Zeno one
time inside detector
this is actually my background so
Franchitti you have a background of you
or your mountainy chile right that's
right so I don't have a mountain on the
ground but this is the hour on the
ground experimental device if you ever
visit Gran Sasso underground lab in
Italy you will see this very beautiful
window building and with all our
instrument inside anyone can go there
and just take pictures and share the joy
the detector that they don't mention
just earlier the one time detector is
shown actually inside on the left side I
like I don't know how I kill my your
cursor yeah if you go to one of these
tools it should it should maybe give you
a toolbar on the screenshare let's see
if annotate and ok I don't know if you
could do that if I'm drawing you see it
yeah yeah hold on the cursor oh I see
your cursor yeah hmm okay so let me
clear the I'm gonna erase my my drawing
there so I use this way you can see my
mouse right yeah so this is the you know
one can't attack here actually and it's
inside a 10 meter diameter water tank
which in the underground side is already
a lot of cosmic me or has already been
shielded but there's a audition of
background from the rocks or whatever
outside of the the detector
we use a big water tank to shield
additional background and the one time
to tell really hiding in the innermost
part really clean and acquire okay no
other instruments is from the outside to
instrument to get signals out of it and
from an array of PMT's as you see
there's a photomultiplier tubes inside
the zener one-time detector looking from
the top and from the bottom and we take
all the signals from this DMPs to a data
acquisition system and then transferred
all around the world you know how people
will access the data and analyze the
data so basically we can actually do the
analysis like even we are locked at home
we can do the analysis and we can look
at all the signals from our data so I'm
not going to give the details of how
these signals are generating it's very
complicated but if anyone's interested I
can answer the questions basically a
particle just get into our detector
would create a scintillation because
since s1 signal and I'll also create
ionization we call it s2
however you know dark matter not only
interactive very rarely but the energy
deposit is also very small so basically
we have to enter Phi this ionization
signal in order to have a clear
detection so any kind of particle can
come in smash a xenon atom ionize it and
liberate electrons and then you directly
detect those electrons which are an
indirect signature of some kind of
particle possibly dark matter etc or
could be background that is responsible
for the ionization due to its kinetic
energy interactions so any kind of
particles including the background can
interact in the
detector produces this kind of s1 and as
two signals we call and we use this s1
as to signal information we can get the
three-dimensional position where this
event has happened in our detector and
also the energy of this any event are
interacting our detector and in addition
we use the information between s1 and s2
to tell what kind of particles actually
they are so whether it's a neutron or a
gamma-ray or electron or dark matter or
neutrinos so really getting from this s1
as some signals so for each event record
register now detector we have a few
heads of the event rate most of them are
background we know but maybe the one out
of a year maybe we see a dark matter
that's the difficulty of the experiment
so the s-1 signal is from the
cylindrical walls effectively or is it
is it so s s2 is the endcaps right the
to the top end cap or the bottom end cap
no s1 is the direct scintillation so
when a particle excited xenon
you know atom the Zener electron will
produce the distant elation immediately
so this gives a kind of a start of this
event yes
now at the same time it produced this
electrons electrons you cannot see it
immediately but we have lecture field
applied in a detector that's why called
time projection Canberra so this
election will slowly drift up and then
on the top there is a gas phase and
there is a very strong field in the gas
phase the reason is that we want to
amplify this election signals into
additional proportional scintillation or
electro luminescence so you turn this
election it may be sometimes only a few
electrons into light signals because I'm
go to multiply tubes on the top
Mireya can only detect light signals
they cannot detect electron signals and
so big both s 1 and s 2 are registered
aim by these photomultiplier tubes many
of them yes right so you see these
events happening everywhere in the
detector and then this scintillation
light will travel the inside the
detectors and eventually hit by the is
PMT's and taken out off by our data
acquisition right I hope this gave you
some idea how the detector works it it's
not so difficult once you understand you
know every time a student come to my
office who want to do research with me I
would give them a paper about instrument
paper and let him to read it and next
week and it come and I asked that the
student to tell me was the principal of
a detector mm-hmm and and most of them
you won't just get it it quickly
you know after reading our paper
announced and how it works and the rest
is just like if you do data analysis
just to deal with this s1 s2 signals how
to get information out of it exactly
right so indeed it's not so it's so
difficult to get into our research but
to build a detector it took years of
effort and we have a large team of 160
scientists around the world many of them
working on the hardware they may not
look at the data but they make sure the
hardware is being perfectly made and so
we can have a sensitive Dark Matter
search now I want to point you to this
picture which is showing the two signals
as called s1 and s2 and there are
particularly two populations one is
called nuclear recoils - collection
recalls dark matter
a heavy dark matter like wing or they
would not to produce election recorders
but they would collide with the nucleus
and it produced a nuclear recall so if
dark matter happens out in our detector
they will appear in this red region
that's what we searched in the past few
years to look for the dogmatic
interaction in Xena one ton and we
didn't find any or didn't find any
convincing evidence they are there so
basically we look at some signals and in
this region and there are few bands and
there some of them look like a dark
matter but more likely a background say
from Neutron and from even from the each
of the top election recall band and in
in this week's announcement what we
actually announced is the search for
some other signals in the election
record we're basically on a top band in
this green band region you see there are
many events so this is the plot actually
choose our science data science search
data so it's not a calibration so it's a
real every event during the Dark Matter
search here on what we registered and
you see there are many of this event in
this top green band electron recalls and
most of them we understand they are from
our background and so in in this
particular search is really challenging
things to try to understand all the
background that can contribute it to
these green band this all the events in
the green band and that took a lot of
effort of our graduates to
and postdocs so by doing that I would
like to show one of the slide of turned
this green band into a one dimensional
plot in the image that is here yes so
this energy is a reconstructed from this
as one as two signals and you see the is
kV kV or is kilo electron volt there's
the energy of each event deposit in our
detector that's election because and and
the vertical axis is event a rate
basically how many events we recorded in
one time year no we didn't see many
events you know only like a 60 something
events per ton year per kvb the red one
is our expect background taking to all
known background and you see on the high
energy we need about 10 kV the data
points that fluctuate up and down up and
down but more or less consistent with
the data but below 7 kv there is a
strange excess that show up it's more
than the background model can can
predict so that excess really caused our
attention during the analysis where they
are coming from and if you just count
the number events the region between 1
to 7 kv we expect 232 events in out of
the total period of our our search and
we observe 285 event so that's like 53
more events observed out of 232
background what about the events and the
bin at 17 and 1/2 kv that's like just
being yeah it's like 2 or 3 signal oh oh
yeah you have a good eye to catch
I'm just used to other people picking
apart my results right so this single
beam is actually you know it's just a
fluctuation it depends on how you pin
this data if you move the pin you know
by a little bit this event or this being
would move a little bit up and then it
will move it down so this single being
access if you take just this being white
it's like a more than three Sigma of
fluctuation but if you move it being a
little bit around then it can shrink to
below 2 Sigma so that so didn't caught
much of our attention the low-energy one
is not a single beam you see
consistently the events is moving up by
after 7 ke V so that you cannot you know
make this fluctuation by just beaming
that differently yes I see there are so
many things just show up so if I use
single beam I wouldn't pay too much
attention but we understand it and the
other thing Kirsch one before we own
this is a little bit nerdy and I want to
keep it a little bit higher level but I
can't resist so if you look at the first
you know seven or eight bins they have
this one over energy fall off at least
until they bottomed out at around 10 to
12 ke V we have fluctuations that are
you know called 1 over F fluctuations 1
over frequency basically meaning if you
wait long enough you know things will
happen and there's a preponderance of
long time scale fluctuations and our
time order data it's the same phenomena
happen in in high in these types where
you have just a preponderance a huge
amount of low energy data compared to
high energy data and then it flattens
out the sort of a flat white noise if
you will a distribution or is that just
not relevant you mean these part abroad
10 kV or from the lowest the second bin
at 2 kV all the way down to you know
here yeah there's sort of a trend in an
energy space is that is that you know 1
over F you know just an excess of low
energy of course the lowest bin is low
much lower
sleep down here why - is that a
phenomena that phenomenon Oh guys look
for now okay so um how detective always
have a so called its threshold right if
you go to lower low energies harder and
hard to detect so you eventually would
see something but fall off that's the
detective Treasury effect um so this
Reata curves has already taken into
account the detector threshold affecting
so-called efficiency and the events here
that show us we really do not expect a
background that's going when we go down
to the energy the background should not
move up the background mainly is from I
want to show you the back one yeah
what's the main background right that's
why we want to look in the main
background is coming from a great
radioactive contamination architect for
the radon radon you know you have your
radon your basement and and we also have
a tiny amount of radon in our liquid
xenon detector and this radon would
produce actually a beta decay from that
to 14 so this led to 14 is a beta decay
so one of the daughter in the rate of
decay chain and this pedir decay would
produce the kind of flat background
they're seeing here this blue line is
the radar okay from 0 to up to 200 kV
hello it's a more or less flat
eventually with the OD 2:04 time at his
endpoint but at a lower energy part it
should be more or less flat and it
should not go up this radon is our main
internal background now back to your
question whether in the low energy we
show there's the kind of detect effect
well we do not expect that from the
power background I see mm-hmm there are
other type of background for example
like this green the orange one is
Krypton 85 Krypton is also a noble gas
it
equipped on 85 you know is in the
atmosphere from all the past a nuclear
test and we have a little bit amount of
Krypton there and that we took a lot of
effort to build it a distillation column
to remove this Krypton and in the
background is soft dominant compared to
the left to take 214 and their other
background we have all taken all this
background into account even including
solar neutrino that we talked about
I mean shooting neutrinos as well yeah
and a solar neutrinos that will not be
shielded by the 1.4 kilometers rock of
gran sasso and it was just enter into
our detectors but the rate is still so
low and compared to other background at
this moment our next next generation
experiment would be able to observe
solar neutrinos that we can study the
neutrinos from the Sun yep okay so up to
you know looking this see in this
success event it's a 36.5 sigma
fluctuation and if we want to see where
where they are coming from and of course
we first we would not think about
something exotic right we want to look
at something maybe stand model another
contamination background that we we we
didn't include it in our standard
background right and that is called a
Chilean yes Julian Oh Julian is one of
the hydrogen isotope and it has a PID K
and it also has a beta decay and of
about twelve years of half-life and and
this Chilean beta decay would produce
the spectrum that can explain the excess
so if you look at this plot the red one
is after we put Chilean into the
consideration to fit our data and the
Chilean is favored at over background
only at 3.2 Sigma the amount of Chilean
in order to explain the success is
really tiny it's got 10 to the negative
20
five more promoter would I think even
put analogies like few then three
trillion atoms per kilogram zina
so that tiny contamination of a Chilean
is not being measured in principle
there's no instrument can measure such a
tiny amount trillion we did the
estimation using old arguments you know
we know including cosmic Janet
activation of xenon that produced
trillion but routing can also be removed
by our distillation column that removed
the Krypton am truly and will be further
removed by our purification system that
we use a purification system to remove
our oxygen water the other contaminants
down to very low level and a trillion
will as well be removed and by
estimation we would expect that if you
know from all the theoretical
calculation Monte Carlo we would expect
that trillion would be if you know
arguments are correct that should be a
hundred times lower even than this value
the basically trillion cannot be
excluded as a possibility but it cannot
cause we also cannot confirm that coming
from Chile so that trigger us to think
about some exotic possibilities
including these soda axioms one question
now which is you know this isn't the
first claim by a dark matter experiment
operating in gran sasso even of a
detection of something which you know
potentially has these groundbreaking
ramifications for physics on speaking of
the dama
experiment now which you know claims
many many dozens of Sigma evidence for
the existence of a signal that they
claim although they're really not
believed by many people in the high
energy you know Astro particle
physicists and dark men or Hunter
community as I understand it I'm not
[Music]
how would this cig no manifest itself
assuming before we go on polar you know
your axioms and things like that
how would it manifest itself over time
would there be an annual their variation
of the kind that Dhamma has reported
with extremely high significance over
the last twenty years with this signal
with the Zenon 1-ton signal if you just
kept operating for a decade would you
see ten cycles of any sort of periodic
event so if it's Chilean um it should
not have an annual cycle trillion with a
decay over time so you you will see them
decaying over that ten years of
half-life so that can be confirmed if we
run a detect for ten years so Xena one
time actually is what is stopped
we are preparing for the next stages you
know hang on which will be have even
lower background that we can tell when
it's functioning or from other exotic
particles
now the signal Tama observe actually is
much higher than what we observe here so
many orders magnitude of rate higher
than their what we have here so it's
completely different story however we
also want to mention here what we
observe the excess is the real of more
than 50 bands more than week set
background the weather dis 50-something
events coming from a background or from
or from some new physics that needs to
be examined
so Chilean is just the one of the
background that we considered one of the
exaggeration of background we consider
and it seems the amount cannot really
explain what we observe but we also
cannot really confidently reject this
hypothesis there might be other
background as you may heard from our
press release there's possibility of
argon 37 but from my naive calculation
37 if he's hiding a man from the air
between two our detector
we would destroy our as one as two
signals completely so so I would likely
mind you know all the experimental
colleagues from the one wall did you see
what are the possibility of the
background before we claim anything but
it's in chicken also to consider it as
signal from solar axioms or as a data or
the data available that someone could
actually do that do what up look for
alternative explanations using actual
Zenon data or or is there a way that we
in our community we publish maps or we
publish power spectra Center are the
data available are they still
proprietary to the Zenon coverage so
data whatever you publish here are the
data we have um I mean I'm just thinking
if there's any other exotic background
that we can use the similar status code
test to check them and people can also
use our public in their life you know
release together with a paper to check
the possibility just by fitting on our
spectrum to see whether the kind of
hypothesis background can fit into our
the fluctuation in our data as well
interesting okay yeah you know in
nevertheless you know whatever
background the amount is so tiny on that
it's really difficult to to be explained
right great so with this in mind we look
into the possibility of solely axiom and
so the axioms is produced by the Sun by
the way and if we fit the there are
three component I don't want to go into
details of what kind of is three
components is that there are three
mechanisms to produce the excellence by
the Sun and but in our detector we can
we can see all the three components by
am detecting the solar axiom so could X
so electric effect that acts
we'll be absorbed by the Zeno atom and
an electron the exact detective so
basically we are looking in to this
electron recall signals to look for
these solar axioms and if you fit all
these spectrums into with together
without data without background in
without data points now these is the
spectrum the raddest spectrum included
the axioms and this epsilon is favorite
of the background has 3.5 Sigma xx
fine-tuning a parameters are there any
parameters that have to be tuned or so
order to get or is it rigidly fixed by
so yeah maybe I better have time we can
look at a little bit about axioms so
excellence produced by the Sun by the
three processes
mostly governing axiom interaction with
electron axial interaction with the
photon and external interaction with the
nucleus and they would produce this kind
of three percent various different kind
of spectrums the ABC process would
produce more dominate at the low energy
the Primakov that excellent photon
coupling would produce this purple
spectrum and the actual neutral nucleon
coupling would produce this a mono
energetic peak and the rate of the three
process can varies depending on the
coupling so we just plot in the same
plot so you can see but the rate can you
know go up and down and we fit them into
our data just by varying the couplings
and see how data can explain so our
detector has some resolution so
eventually if you take in our detection
efficiency and a reconstructing
resolution then you would expect the
signal as three component would like
that and there are some pumps you know
the curve
tips compared with trillion is the
really a kind of ship is a smooth curve
going down but here there are some
curvatures so that makes some difference
of that they are fitting arm for the for
the solar axiom and if you look at data
you know when I saw this you know it
looks like there is a dealer there is a
pump but of course you know we have to
rely on the stitches so test to make
make a quantity analysis and this
three-point prime Sigma is it's more
favored compared to the trillion
hypothesis of 3.26 mm-hmm that I think
that caused the excitement of
possibility of this is really coming
from the solar excellence instead of a
background but we really cannot claim
that we have to have detected that solar
axiom eventually you know we need a five
Sigma of significant C in order to claim
a detection and that has to rely on our
next-generation detectors you know in
town I see right yeah so I want also
mention you know if we take this fitting
and then put into the couplings of the
XE on what could it be
for right and this is the one of the the
GAE is the coupling of X G onto election
da Gama is a epsilon to photon and the
xenon one can work would in this blue
region okay I won't say you know there
are other experiments that's researching
for solar action like cost and the cost
has set a very strong limit on the GA
gamma the axiom photon coupling and
anything above this green line has to be
excluded but the below this line is
still valid and and but in our case this
is a GA erection
electron coupling it's quite different
in tension with this so called stellar
cooling now if the Sun can emit action
the the stars can
also a man accion and and that by the
estimation from the Stella coding we can
estimate what amount of kind of copying
that required that the energy loss of
the stars and this is from astrophysics
analysis and I got questions from my
edge of his colleagues say oh this is
the intention with the xenon one time if
your company is too large right and
there's also almost one orders of
magnitude right so you know I'm a
particle physicist I want to learn more
about astrophysics that what actually
was this tension maybe our result is
really not axial but maybe there is also
a surface process that can cause such a
one orders of magnitude difference so I
think that's interesting to think about
the possibility of the astrophysics and
looking to the calculations but I'm open
to you know I still would rely on my
experiment our experiment the next
generation to say more about the direct
evidence of actual actual coupling you
think the the topic people have been
most curious about is yeah these results
from yeah these cooling experiments and
I'm not an expert not all extra
physicists or are knowledgeable about
all different types of limits but this
is certainly I think the most you know
kind of interesting and as as as Richard
Feynman once said you know the the first
principle of being a scientist is you
must not fool yourself and and the
realization that we have to have is that
we're the easiest to fool and that if
you always think that way it really
translates as you described into not
trusting your own results and and really
not not trusting him that you didn't
made a mistake but that the explanation
that you want or you know in your heart
of hearts you'd most like to be true is
is you know has to be you know the final
hypothesis it has to be survived the
test of all possible other sources
including
backgrounds including contaminants and
so forth so I was wondering you know in
the future
you said you can't directly measure the
tritium and that's sort of a most
prosaic explanation on earth at least
for background but you know ii thought
you know why not get a hundred liters of
tritium liquid tritium and do an
experiment i mean first of all I think
that would cost more than the GDP of the
planet but but are there other ways to
go after tritium and are there other
ways to you know possibly may do a
detection that could remove what we call
a systematic error potential sources
systematic error and and or calibrate
the instrument better in other words how
much our energy are going to put into
better calibration versus bigger
fiducial volume so four trillion
actually we Chilean has been used for
calibrating the xeno detectors we didn't
use the quasi no one tongue but I had a
test in 0-100 our previous generation
detector at the end of the Zener 100 and
also in the lux experiment has used the
Chilean for calibrating the detector so
we really understand the Chile
inspection well how it in the forms in
the xenon detector xenon one time we
didn't use cheating at all for
calibration and if if a tiny amount
trillion where they come you from theirs
do a puzzle when I talk about the next
generation is really the genome and
tongue and we expect a background will
be lower to by factor six compared to
xenon one time so so that means that
that the the background the flat
background would be further suppressed
then if it's Chilean you would see them
much better mm-hm and if it's also axiom
then you would see this spectrum better
that's why we say with the Zeno and
tongue we would be able to have better
discrimination between the Chilean
hypothesis and a solar axonal hypothesis
with a lower background I see I think
that's the only way from experimentally
how do we disentangle these two
hypotheses so this it will not be ten
years away I hope in the next year we
would be able to say something of this
mm-hmm so you think okay and so tell us
yeah so NT what does that stand for not
nine tons cuz the colon and tone in toto
inside this time projection chamber is
six times compared to the two ton of
sensor target of Xena 1g so it's like
three times the active volume and so
this n we can replace the with six or
but it has been calling n because we are
struggling to get the madina and more
funding to fill the detectors now
anybody knows the you know and tongue so
we just give it a name so I have thanks
I have some questions from the audience
one is could there be such a thing as a
accion or perhaps a Dark Matter planet
could there be
you know condensed bodies in which these
objects exist I think I have some
colleagues did they have some you know
paper about excellent stars and that's
the interesting thing to look at and I
had really have no clue I know I have
very limited about this but if you
search axiom stars there was some paper
you can okay it's interesting idea and
there are some including Eric Weinstein
has been on my podcasts a lot lately he
has some thoughts about whether or not
dark matter could be a manifestation
perhaps of extra dimension Jeannette
ality or higher dimensions so forth what
do you make of that that you know it may
be signatures of alternative you know
something called the parallel universes
but let's just say you know extra
dimensions that are maybe compactified
extremely small but but it manifests
themselves over via modification of
gravitational force um on on scales
relevant for experiments like this I
think so twenty days
ability mm-hm yeah and what we are
looking for now the dark matter is in
this three-dimensional universe that has
in some other models consider symmetry
that would produce such kind of coda
relics from the other universe and but
there are other models think about it
that mean coming from actual dimensions
and there are possibilities and there
are some models that we can test but
first we have to see an excess in our
data I'm Greg and I exam all this kind
of possibility and just briefly cuz I
don't often get the chance to interview
my friends and co-workers here and in
forums such as this but about a year ago
you had a result on xenon itself
can you talk oh I believe that's right
correct oh yeah we yeah we did have a
result a year ago about observing the
various the decays ever directly
measured in the xenon one time
that's called double electron capture of
as ISO score xenon 124 in our detector
now this is not exotic physics it's a
standard model process but really the
decay lifetime is is much billions of
times of the age of universe and that it
turns out our low back for now we'll be
able to find that signature hmm-what
double beta a double electron capture
that observation is interesting it's
challenging but is not as interesting as
another process called a neutrinoless
double beta decay or neutrinoless double
beta decay would eventually help us to
understand the nature of neutrinos where
there is a mariana particle and direct
particle and what's the absolute mass of
neutrinos and these things are really in
the heart of my interest very good well
I know you've got a lot of things to get
to it's been a busy week for you much
deserved congratulations on your
phenomenal work of you and your team and
especially all the Tritons out
working so hard can you tell people how
to find out more about you on the web
and on Twitter and elsewhere
oh hi T I have a Twitter calm you know
sometimes I share my own opinion of a
result but if you want to find more
about you know one ton experiment it's
easy zero one tdawg that's the website
look for you can also find the Xenon
Twitter account on Facebook Twitter
Instagram you know our new generation of
students post octi I really could add a
child a story from just such Posey non
experiment in Google than you on all of
them that's great
well Chi Chuan as a pleasure to call you
a friend and a colleague here at UC San
Diego we have the best scientist in my
opinion in the world that work here I'm
a little bit biased but thank you so
much for sharing so much of your
valuable time and I look forward to much
many more exciting results to come from
you and your stellar team Thank You Chi
Chuan thank you I look forward to meet
you on campus soon yes hopefully it will
be soon but this is the next best thing
thanks guys Sean have a wonderful
weekend happy Father's Day to by the way
early oh thank you oh yeah I had my
father and you are sought out more than
more tonnage she wanted more tonnage of
kids for now for now maybe who knows why
she wouldn't have a wonderful day thank
you so much I gave you thank you I